at this orphanage in the Ganan coastal
town of Sena baraku the name of
Christian atsu won't easily be forgotten
atsu supported the children at this home
just one example of the impact he had
away from
football he was like a father to us
everything he takes us then we all play
together we have fun we eat together in
some point of life he went and we still
have hope in God that he's going to
bring new people to come and support and
then we can reach our destination
whenever he's around his donation
towards personal donations he comes with
like tons of bags of
rice uh Milo sugar what like a lot of
stuff and gives us money he comes to
advise the children helps them in
reading and play with
them ATU lost his life during last
year's earthquakes while playing in
turkey's domestic League a state funeral
was held in Ghana for the 31-year-old
who represented his country on 65
occasions at the orphanage prayers for
atsu are said every Sunday I see more of
a philanthropist a charitable person
even more than a footballer because now
we can't find
his legs or his feet on the field but we
can see the works that he has done on
our VAR in our various places the people
that he has helped and the charitable
works that he has left behind atsu was
planning to build a football pitch at
the home and his financial support was
helping the children fulfill their
career Ambitions such projects now face
an uncertain future without atsu's
backing David Stokes Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz